good afternoon this is um my name is
Henry newfeld I'm head of the climate
change unit um at the world Agro
forestry Center ikra in Nairobi in Kenya
and I welcome you very much to this uh
discussion forum organized by erra
together with FAO and um while we start
going through a quick round of
introductions um I hope that there will
be more people coming in and uh so that
we take as much time as we can for
discussions
afterwards the title of this uh session
is called using climate Smart
Technologies to scale up climate smart
Agriculture and forget the practices
it's a bit of a toogy but and I
apologize um climate smart agriculture
has had quite a bit of a um let's
say it's it's been a very shiny kind of
brand coming up um it's managed to unite
sort of the development the Agriculture
and the climate change communities under
one brand and in doing so it's raised a
lot of
expectations um term has been around for
about four or 5 years there are a couple
of
Publications uh that have been put
forward around CL climate smart
agriculture what it really is what it
could be and um still we lack we still
do lack a bit of an understanding of
what it could actually do and this
session here is uh also meant to bring
shed a bit of light on that question
um there has been uh a Global Alliance
for climate smart agriculture which was
launched uh recently at the climate
change Summit in September m in the in
New York uh there was also there's also
an African uh Alliance for climate smart
Agriculture and we will also talk about
these um two new institutions and what
they can potentially deliver uh in
resolving issues around food security uh
adaptation and
mitigation so uh let me just quickly
introduce uh our speakers first um we
have Alexandre Maybeck who is a senior
policy officer uh on agriculture
environment and climate change in the
office of the assistant director General
uh within the FAO then our second
keynote speaker is Todd rosenstock who
is an agro ecologist with erra and he
investigates how smallholder agriculture
affects the environment and
Society um and then we have panelists
here sitting U next to me we have here
uh sorry where is she she
Lami in I'm sorry I can I I can't get
the name right in inua I think is she's
a manager for communications and
knowledge at feran the food agriculture
and natural resources policy analysis
network with 21 years of experience in
policy research and
advocacy uh then we have Martin Bia he's
the head of the comprehensive
agriculture Africa agriculture
development program katup within uh
nepad and
finally last but not least Austin Tibu
uh he's been working as a land resources
conservation officer at Malawi's
Ministry for of Agriculture irrigation
and water for over 10 years and he's
also the FAO focal point for economics
and policy Innovations for
CSA in the epec Epic program and then um
we will have Richie auua who's sitting
here in front he is um an expert in
business development strategy and
spearheads the environmental defense
funds engagement in Asia uh he will be
rapturing he will give us a short
summary at the end of the the session so
without losing any more time I'm going
to ask Alexandre to say a few words
about um what climate smart agriculture
is some backgrounds opportunities and
challenges and then we'll hear what uh
Todd has to say about climate smart
agriculture Panacea or prop propaganda
okay please Alexander thank you very
much and yeah move that yeah
y so uh I will very briefly introduce or
reintroduce for those of you who who
already uh know what climate smart
ulture is what the the way we understand
climate smart agriculture in in FAO
which can be slightly different some
from some of the things uh that are
around more and more
and just extremely briefly giving
examples because examples is probably
the best way to understand what uh
climate smart agriculture uh could
mean so once again agriculture has to
address a triple challenge more food in
quantity quality and diversity
everywhere for everyone adapt to climate
change and contribute to mitigate
climate change the important point I
think is that this triple challenge has
to be seen at very various scales Global
local local and and household and we
always need to keep in mind these
various scales when you look at systems
and and what can be their contributions
to climate smart
agriculture growing demand all over the
world um due also to to diet changes but
especially in some countries and and
many of these countries which are
already food insecure and which will be
the most affected by climate change and
globally worldwide fa estimates that
production has to increase by
60% very briefly main effects on of
climate change on agricultural
production a decrease of production in
certain areas a change in the geography
of of production between countries and
inside countries and also and especially
uh an increased variability of
production so the the impacts on on food
and nutrition security have have been
well described in in the hlp reports
2012 and now in the ipcc report uh
recently released with impacts on the
most vulnerable countries and the most
vulnerable people mainly and with
impacts on food security and nutrition
which are much more than just decreasing
yields decreasing yields and the
consequences of decreasing yields
changes of the geography of production
and so vulnerable all countries having
to import and price volatility and the
combination of all these
effects so agriculture can also
contribute to mitigate and the way we
see it uh in in FAO given the fact that
agriculture has to produce more is to
understand mitigation as a reduction of
emissions per kilo of
output globally having emissions
increasing less than production
and also uh enhanced agricultural soil
carbon sinks which means sinks above and
underground so the concept has first
been introduced in 2010 it with the
title of a brochure that FAO prepared
for the the ha
conference one so it's amazing how the
the word is now all over the place
probably because this idea that we need
to address various
objectives at Farm level at Country
level and globally is really
needed and also one other important
point about the climate smart a culture
approach is that it is not only
practices or systems but also systems
from an ergonomic point of view but also
the policies and institutions and the
finance which are necess to enable these
changes so it's really the three of
them with to a certain extent why I
climate smart I don't know what is a
climate smart technology i' I'd rather
think about climate Smart
Systems and when you try to take these
three objectives together food security
adaptation and mitigation globally what
we want to do is more resource efficient
systems and more resilient systems Sy
but be also careful to what we mean want
to mean by resource efficient systems
it's not only more crop per drop it's
also more income per drop more jobs per
drop in the countries where agriculture
is the main source of jobs and and
income for the
population which means that it is very
country local system specific the the
way you imagine the Technologies and the
way they are integrated in a system and
globally what what we think is that the
tradeoffs are not really between food
security and mitigation or food security
and adaptation but rather because
between increasing resource efficiency
and increasing
resilience and this is where you have to
look at tradeoffs and
synergies an important point which is
why I was insisting on the various
levels in the system is that we need to
increase the general resilience of Food
Systems which means the physical
resilience environmental but also the
economic and social resilience of the
system one of these Dimension being able
to compensate for a certain time but not
for a very long time but for instance
social protection can help farmers
resist a physical shock avoid them
selling all their livestock for instance
and enable them to recover
afterwards but resilience has also to be
seen at various levels each level being
able to compensate for another the
resilience of his household depends on
the fact also on the fact that they're
Diversified the Diversified sources of
income but also it can be compensated by
social protection for instance trade can
play a role to a certain extent provided
that there income so that why I we were
insisting on the need to understand how
the various systems relate one to
another household to the farm the farm
to the landscape the the farm to the
food chain and all of that constitutes
various Food
Systems so really very very quickly and
and you'll hear much more about it after
me understanding climate smart
agriculture has to be done on the ground
in the field in in in real systems so
these are just examples of a brochure
you'll found you'll found
downstairs where we
tried uh to look
at the various dimensions of the impact
of a technique in in other words and to
come back to the title of my
presentation we believe that there are
opportunities to have climate Smart
Systems more efficient and more
resilient but the challenge is to be
able to properly measure the various
impacts of the techniques both
environmentally economically and
socially and in various time frames and
these are very different according to
the system it's not the same if you
introduce Ura de placement in Bangladesh
where jobs are very uh low coast and you
need more jobs
and in China for instance where job
labor is much more coly so you need
mechanized systems and and the impact on
food Security will be totally different
in the various systems and very often
what happens is that which is what where
climate smart agriculture makes the
change we've introduced a technology for
a precise objective and we measure that
precise objective we have the basine on
water and we and we measure how water is
used very often we don't have the impact
on economics on livelihoods on income on
social issues on gender sens sensitivity
Etc so these are some cases where we
have them sustainable grazing for better
livelihoods in China this is an
interesting project because in the
beginning it was introduced as a
mitigation project uh to increase carbon
sinks but in fact it is totally
transforming the systems and the
livelihood of the people and it's much
more a food security and an adaptation
project with a carbon Finance component
but it is this carbon Finance component
which began triggering the the
institutional
changes uh you'll hear probably more
about these one uh
afterward insisting also on the
important of genetic di diversity just
as an example of of things that that we
need in order to be able to react to
uncertainties and this is another very
important dimension of climate smart
agriculture when we say increasing
resilience we mean resilience to
everything because we do not know
exactly what are going to be the changes
in 30 or 40 years in in whatever area
landscape approach is also a key
one um I've already mentioned that one
and I will stop here to leave the floor
to
my colleague thank
[Applause]
you so what I'm going to be talking
about today is trying to answer oh it's
cut off hopefully not all of the slides
are like that uh what I'll be talking
about today is trying to answer this
simple or somewhat complicated question
climate smart agriculture propaganda or
Panacea and here in like this title
slide this question is incredibly
complicated especially for climate smart
agriculture because with climate smart
agriculture what we're talking about in
many cases is multiple Dimensions we're
talking about multiple practices here
you can see it's Agro forestry
intercropping uh conservation
agriculture improved cook stoves as well
as multiple outcomes so we're looking at
nutrition security we're looking at
poverty alleviation we're looking at
natural resource management and so how
do we even begin to think about and
begin to analyze this type of complexity
I would tend that it's this type of
complexity that has largely made the in
and helped spur the debate about whether
or not climate smart agriculture can
actually achieve some of its Ambitions
and it's because of this we need to pull
back from some of the sort of IND
idiosyncratic case studies and try to
get to the real big issues that we can
then uh start to bring these these
topics to
scale so over the next about 10 10
minutes or so I'm going to be telling
you about the initial results from a
meta analysis that that we've been
conducting about specifically to try to
answer the question of How do farm
management
practices affect food security uh add
adaptive capacity and mitigation and so
I was sort of inspired to take on this
topic largely because I was seeing
things like this in the news uh the
Global Alliance for CSA wants to reach
500 million small holder farming
households uh the African CSA Alliance
and the knad vision 25 by 25 want to
reach 25 million households by 2025 this
type of effort will require a Herculean
change in how we as scientists and we as
development practitioners actually
Implement agricultural development and
so but the real question here is what is
the evidence base all of this type of
development initiatives is fundamentally
based on the assumption that we have
evidence for that improved practices CSA
uh will improve food security uh
adaptive capacity and mitigation
objectives while and also it's based on
the fundamental assumption that we have
so idea about the synergies and
tradeoffs between these different
components and so what have we been
doing so far we've been trying to make a
sense of essentially what is a pile of
disperate
literature and so we've been doing a
meta analysis and a systematic review of
65 practices and 15 indicators and so
when I say practices we're not talking
about the aggregate level of Agro
forestry we're talking about things that
farmers actually Implement on the on the
ground leguminous intercrop AGR
Forestry deep placement of Ura things
that farmers would actually need that
you can analyze individually and then
also aggregate back up when I talk about
indicators these are indicators of food
security adaptive capacity or mitigation
uh for food security we're looking at
four main indicator categories of
ranging from income productivity and and
such in terms of adaptive capacity
obviously this is the hardest one we're
thinking about things like soil quality
we're thinking about gender
differentiated labor we're thinking
about nutrient use efficiency water use
efficiency and things like that
mitigation is a little bit more
straightforward carbon sequestration uh
greenhouse gas intensity and the like
and so what we've done is essentially we
we utilize discipline oriented keyword
searches in the web of science database
and we came up with 144,000 candidate
papers and with the help of a small team
in of of Master's level students
including Helena who's in the audience
here today uh we went through all
144,000 papers and tried to see how they
matched our inclusion criteria so here
we were interested in whether or not
there was they had information and data
on a CSA practice and a non-csa control
as well as whether or not they took
place in a tropical developing country
so from that 144,000 we narrow in
Reading those abstracts we narrowed it
down to about 16,000 papers and those
papers we then downloaded the full text
and further analyzed them to see if they
met our inclusion criteria that left us
with uh 6,000 papers in which we had to
actually extract data from that we
thought were relevant to answering our
main question which is uh climate smart
agriculture panace propaganda or in
other words what is the evidence based
behind climate smart agriculture so far
we've extracted data on about 20% of
that and so I'll be talking about that
based on the numbers that we've already
extracted we presume that in the end
this database which will be hopefully
ready by the MIAA conference if not a
little a little bit later on in the year
we'll have about 120,000 individual data
points in it
okay and so if we start and so if we
just start to map the where the studies
have taken place to see where and how
and what information is available these
are the studies that we have this is a
random sample from our 12200 studies
that we've already looked at um where
they where they are actually located on
the map and these Studies have they're
talking about at least one indicator
relevant for food security adaptive
Capac capacity or mitigation you see
that it's a pretty good global
distribution but if you look a little
closer you also see that there is some
Geographic clustering that you see that
in Western Kenya and maybe around Acra
and Ghana there's actually um quite a
number of studies that are in relatively
small location and what so what does
that mean for when we're trying to scale
climate smart agriculture well what it
means is or what it suggests at this
point is that we may have a biased data
set that our information base may be
inadequate to be able to say say uh that
this type of practice will have this
type of outcome in a in a new location
when we then go to uh studies that have
two
practices or two that address two
components of CSA like food security and
adaptation in the same study the um the
size of the data set reduces
dramatically you B we basically lose 60%
of the studies and so why is that
important that's important because what
we know from about 50 years of
agricultural research and agricultural
for de development research is that a
lot of time interventions are
place-based so we can't presume that the
types of interventions and the types of
outcomes that we might see in one
location are going to be able to be
extrapolated to another location quite
easily and so these synergies and
tradeoffs may not actually U be
transmissable and lastly if we look at
studies where we have all three
indicators May probably given this
projector you might not even see any up
there there's but there's a seven dots
so we we basically reduced it to less
than 1% of the studies have looked at
all three all three components of CSA in
the same study and this is this is
important simply because it greatly
reduces our ability to characterize what
is normally thought of within climate
smart agriculture which are these triple
winds these win-win
winds when we start to look at the data
and actually use uh common meta
analytical techniques so this is uh they
food security response across multiple
indicators for six different practices
at different aggregated levels and
that's sounds a little complicated but
let me let me go into uh a little bit
more detail and so wrong button so this
is an effect size so an effect size
measures the relative effect of the
treatment to the control and so anything
to the right of that red line is a
positive effect anything to the left of
that line is going to be a negative
effect uh if it crosses that line it's
not significantly different than zero
and you can you may have positive or
negative control or negative effects and
so basically what you see here is that
there's not only a wide variability for
any given practice for instance in Agro
forestry or but there are some uh clear
winners the use of inorganic fertilizer
seems to be quite positive uh the use of
increasing protein and livestock feeds
as well the interesting part is is that
in most cases people are talking about
climate smart agriculture at a very
aggregate level they're talking about
agroforestry as climate smart well as
you can see in these top two two panels
uh if once you start disaggregating the
data from AGR forestry to actually
leguminous AGR forestry the actual
effect changes and so I I would argue
that you would need to actually begin to
think about it in this more disaggregate
level when you're identifying things as
climate
smart and lastly let's let's look quick
quick L at some synergies and some
tradeoffs and so this is just the
synergies and tradeoffs uh for the
adaptation and food security indicators
that are are in 130 random
samp random sample of 130 studies so as
you can see there are only 55
comparisons in that in that 130 study so
that's back to the about 60% decline
that I mentioned earlier and everything
in the red box in the lower leftand
corner is where you don't want to be
this is lose lose so about 6% of the
studies showed that there were lose lose
effects between adaptation and food
security uh in the opposite quarter in
catac cornia there's about 32% of them
showed that there were actually
synergies so this is what everybody is
saying is possible with climate smart
agriculture but equally important 60% of
the studies that we that we looked at
and granted it a small data set at this
point shows that there's equal or more
likely chance of actual trade-offs
between adaptation and food security
than there are synergies
and so so while today I just really
focused on a very small amount of our
initial data the merging Trends seem to
be clear somewhere clear that there's
Geographic uh clustering of the studies
which would suggest that we have
challenges in actually extrapolating the
data there's a likelihood that we will
see uh tradeoffs as much as we would see
synergies as well as that there's large
variability amongst and with and between
and within individual practices than
[Applause]
thanks okay thank you so before we go to
some questions we'll have another uh
round of panelists giving their sort of
views on what they've just heard also
just making some statements in regard to
let's say the alliance here so let's
start off with Martin and then um Lami
and Austin in that order and um I'll ask
you to be fairly brief so that we have
as much time as possible for questions
and answers where you can sort of uh
elaborate more on any issues you might
want to raise okay so Martin you want to
kick us off
please thank you very much okay yes
thank you so much moderator Hy
yes I'm going to be very brief and thank
you so much to the two
presentations I think they do give us a
very good scope in terms of the
discussion now and I pick it up from the
messages key messages out of the two
presentations and I would
say is it possible looking at what we've
just heard in terms of what is clim SM
agriculture is it possible then or is it
correct to say that in
fact climate smart agriculture is just
any good agricultural
practices anything that is actually good
and underlying the word good is going to
give us productivity food security is
going to give us adaptation it's going
to give us mitigation
value uh and sometimes when you look
back into uh what we have described and
what we've known as good agricultural
farming when we say climate smart
agriculture are we saying anything
different what is new in in this ER and
I start by
saying that yes in fact there there is
something new there is something
different uh one of the first important
issue is
that in dealing with and talking about
CLI smart agriculture we want to go
beyond
just the issue of securing productivity
so this is more than just productivity
issue there is something that is
actually very very clear about the
threats that climate change or the
opportunities that climate change bring
on the whole spectrum and space on
productivity and on the Food Systems so
you looking at the everything that we're
doing in terms of farming practices or
what you call Agriculture and look at
how far is it going to
support enhancing ability to deal with
the
new emerging Trends and and threats
opportunities that are very specific to
the occurrence of climate change climate
variability and this again is about
understanding the actual risks which are
actually going are very localized is
appreciating the actual opportunity
unities that you attribute to to that
climate change uh the second point I
want to make is
the is that when you look at clim smart
agriculture in terms of what is
different and in terms of those
practices is actually that is something
that is compelling Beyond we talk about
holistic comprehensive approaches but in
climate smart agriculture we are seeing
a very practical compare to look at
agriculture to look at farming in a very
very integrated holistic and I like what
the the moderator was saying in the
beginning that is more than just climate
Smart Technologies but that we we look
at climate Smart Systems because it's
about practices it's about policies and
institutions as mentioned resources but
is also about managing the tradeoffs in
terms of different constituencies
but also the tradeoffs in in time and
space so what are we doing today Visa
what are the needs requirements of
future scenario and the last and third
point in terms of the practices of clim
smart agriculture is actually the value
and the one issue about clim smart
agriculture is actually how much it
should bring back the value the benefits
into the local circumstances both in
terms of environmental resilience social
resilience but today especially when you
look at Africa the issues how do we
support the communities to harness their
resources land and water in terms of
increasing access to economic or
expanding economic opportunities and and
actually enabling them to move in that
Spectrum towards Prosperity thank
you okay thank you you very much Martin
um we now have Fabiola um Muno Doo who
is the executive director of the
national forest and Wildlife service
surfor here as well
um it's a Pity she couldn't make it to
us a little earlier because she missed
the the presentations but I'll give her
the the chance of listening to the
respondents so then she can make
something out of that and uh we'll have
more chances to hear afterwards okay
well thank you very much for coming
anyway it's been it's great to have
you Lami please good afternoon ladies
and
gentlemen uh when I was being introduced
they said that I'm working for an
organization where working in a policy
space I would like to throw that into
the discourse of you know climate smart
agriculture uh I listen to the
presentations and I also listen to the
the presentations before this session a
yesterday what I'm seeing as a missing
link it's the enabling environment that
we all agree that it's part of what will
make you know our efforts for climate
smart agriculture to be
successful I just want to share with you
uh the experience that just we had uh
with our organization where we did uh
some scoping studies in 15 countries in
Africa southern Africa and East Africa
to see how the countries are actually
responding in terms of you know the
climate smart agriculture debates and
also climate change what we are seeing
is that that the countries do recognize
that climate change is there they also
respond to the to the calls for climate
change and most of the discussions are
hosted by the ministries of of
environment what we have seen with the
ministries of agriculture culture is
that uh out of the 15 countries that we
we we we did the scoping study there
were about four five where they have
policies that speaks specifically to
climate smart agriculture so as we
discuss I would like us to to look at
how we can actually accelerate you know
really for the countries to have the
enabling environment that will
complement what is happening on the
ground so we find you know the
disjuncture that you know on the ground
there a lot of experiences there a lot
of practices that is happening but
there's a gap between what is being
practiced and what the policies are
saying so as we discussed we need to to
also accelerate on that front thank
you thank you very much Lami that's a
very important point and Alexander
already mentioned it that we need not
only look at the Technologies that's
very
important uh Austin please just give us
your your
thoughts oh thank you very much uh
moderator um from the
introduction I think I'm the most ta end
panelist
here um I am from the extension side
of uh all these practices so I'll Focus
my comment on what it takes to scale up
um climate smart agricultural
practices um I like the matrics that
toad presented I think it's four
dimensional but as we go out in the
field the matrics could become 100
dimensional um when we are working with
um the farming
communities uh the issues of
productivity yes they come in issues of
costs the issues of resource saving
environmental issues or
indicators and also the institutional uh
indicators that we have discussed in um
the presentation from uh
FAO so uh when we are at that level we
must uh make sure that um all those
indicators are satisfied and that's the
main challenge uh that we Face uh in
climate smart agriculture
we have observed
that those practices uh they do respond
to as many of those
indicators and my suggestion to the
metod study that we are conducting under
aircraft is that we should um go on
beyond the three indicators to satisfy
what the farming communities need or
what they expect from this practice IES
and uh
finally uh I'd like to suggest that we
have quick policy briefs to our decision
making people the
politicians uh
that crisply presents what we expect or
what we
suggest uh uh the winning solutions to
the challenge that the farming
communities are facing in the the
because of the effects of climate change
thank
you thank you Austin and that's very
important for us to talk about the
question of scaling up I think we should
hear uh more about that um it's one
thing to know the benefits in terms of
uh adaptation mitigation and food
security but then another question
altogether might be how can it how can
we reach these millions of farmers that
uh Todd was already mentioning Fabiola
do you want to say a few words with
regard to climate smart Agriculture and
U potentially uh your own experience
here out of the country I don't know
e
El for
l
in
min
min in
uh
pardon okay
buo for
[Music]
okay thank thank you
so I think you did added a very
important element and gave some more
sort of depth to the question of what
contributes to enabling environments
from the political perspective and I
think that was very useful for our
audience here so we have quite a bit of
time for questions and then uh so I'd
like to take two or three questions at a
time and then uh we'll give a give our
panel an opportunity to respond I have
Jonathan here in the back um
yes sir number two and we'll take one
more
afterwards what go ahead Jonathan yeah
my name is Jonathan Cornelius um a
question actually for for Fabiola can
you introduce yourself please not the
institution okay sorry Henry this is
Jonathan Cornelius I'm regional
coordinator for World agrology Center
based here in
Lima okay um yeah a question for faola T
your interesting remarks about the need
to close the gap between research and
policy
yeah and coincidentally possibly um in
our institutions the CG we spend a lot
of time thinking about theories of
change and how our research can change
what happens
uh to its intended or rather can
change uh what our intended uh users do
should we say in this case how our
research can change policy what I'd like
to ask you as a as
a uh
implementer and
former of policy is to what
degree um the El at end users of
research also have to
come back
down the the the chain of impact
themselves and somewhere uh meet the the
scientists as they try increasingly to
work forwards in in the chain of impact
yeah um hope I'm being clear what I'm
trying to say is that as researchers we
are being asked to be increasingly
accountable uh for our research being
implemented for example in changing
policies
so uh what is the role of policy makers
in also coming back maybe towards
researchers and for the two of us
together uh to construct um that impact
that we all
want thank
you okay please yes
sir and then the lady behind him um as
well thank you I'm Doug Boucher from the
union of concerned scientists um my
question is for Todd um the graph you
showed had what to me was a striking and
even paradoxical result which is that a
a very large uh quite impressive
metaanalysis from the world Agro
forestry Center showed that there was no
significant effect of Agro
forestry um but you were only talking
about the effects on food
security what were the significant
variables that affected uh
mitigation okay
inter
[Music]
okay let's uh give the panel the
opportunity to respond and uh yes let's
start with Fabiola and uh then I'll pass
it on to to Todd and um anybody else who
wants to say something to any of the
other questions please feel free okay
famba
okay
for
for for
e
J
pH
quantos AOS
see for
[Music]
okay thanks for this uh passionate
statement Fabiola
um and I think you're totally right
about everything
uh see Todd why don't you just respond
to dog's question I think it's a
important question dou easy to follow up
great appreciate that um I I fail to see
the Parx uh mostly because I'm a
scientist and I just I report what the
data say and so this is the analysis
that that we've done so far in the
limited data set what you see and what
you saw in that graph is largely driven
by the variability in aggro forestry
systems that are included there there's
border planting there's intercrop
there's there's legumes there's Timber
species and all of that which which is
why you see such a wide such a wide
range in the effect and so I would I
would presume that before the end of the
analysis when you we've included more
data um that you we would we would see a
different effect how large that effect
positive or negative I'm not I can't
it's hard for me to predict right now
based on my reading of the 1200
papers oh the mitigation effects we
haven't looked at those data yet okay
Martin do you want to say something
about
the the question that Jonathan raised in
the context of Science and policy I
think you might be able to add a few
words from your perspective maybe put it
into the context of the climate smart
agriculture
Alliance yes thank you uh indeed that is
an interesting issue and it does come up
all the time in fact in the in the
Africa Alliance one of the work stream
we have identified where we saying we
need need to make a difference is on is
on the on the policy we have one on the
policy stream and we have one which
we're calling technical support and this
is the appreciation of the fact that and
I think in Africa you can say the
politicians are
coming quite a long way in respecting
data respecting evidence and beginning
to talk about facts and figures and the
problem is that this facts and figures
data is not existing in the form in the
manner that they can actually use it at
the moment and that is the problem we
have so the the issue in terms of
research is actually how we can move and
actually move very rapidly not just in
terms of Technology development but also
support the politicians to answer the
questions they need to answer in terms
of real with the evidence with the
objectivity
that is desired and one of the things we
are looking at actually as a as a matter
of approach is that when you talk about
climate smart
Agriculture and and look looking at at
science is a very open space there's a
lot we need to know but is also clear
that the climate smart agriculture we're
talking about in fact as implied from
the various discussions is not the same
as manufacturing a kind Laboratory and
then take it out on the road to be used
the car the clim smart agriculture is
going to be developed in situ is going
to image within the road that you're
using it so it's how we move actually in
terms of research approaches in terms of
research Tools in terms of the
accountability of what research delivers
to actually bring them into the field
working with the farmers working with
politicians working with communities and
and actually it's also because it's not
just a technical issue is actually
political economy and and those things
will be critical in making climate smart
agriculture image the way we want to see
it we've mentioned actually working with
the Cs we're working with far and we're
saying also that we need in fact just as
much political economy research as we're
doing on the on the hardware on the on
the on the actual agronomic and and
technological
practices uh moderator if you allow me
just one more point I wanted also to say
that when you look at the sorry
discussions on climate smart agriculture
everywhere even in the this this two
days of course it's being emphasized in
terms of the the comprehensiveness the
integrated nature of it the holistic
aspects uh but it's also linking to
research to understand that I think we
have to be careful that we don't end up
with a very perfect creation that is
unimplementable and and actually the the
Excellency of the description of climate
smart agriculture is not going to come
out of a laboratory it's going to come
out of real practices in the field and I
want to end by saying in fact in that
sense that's why we need to listen more
from what the farmers are doing what
communities are doing and actually
understand that if it's not broken don't
fix it
brilliant okay I saw I had you sir then
um I saw you first and I don't know if
you were there so I have you three okay
please introduce yourself
please can we get a a microphone here
see first no I saw this gentleman first
he was uh already raising his hand I'm
sorry thank you uh Doug brown with World
Vision International um my question's
specifically to Todd but I think
Alexandre might be able to help with it
as well um your data surprised me a
little bit in a way it was but I think
it's partly because it's a ma m analysis
and of course you're looking at studies
that were designed to measure food or
productivity impacts or at resilience
impacts but they may not have measured
the other ones and so they're dropped
out when you sort of start comparing to
um so there's a limitation there I guess
but I was looking at the grid the quadr
here where you have the win-wins the
lose lose and then the mixed ones and
I'm just trying to wonder I know when in
the FAO Source book we know that there's
a lot of practices listed there and
they're not all equally climate smart
some score better on two or three
dimensions than others do so I'm
wondering if you can characterize what's
in the upper right quadrant versus
what's in the lower the upper left
versus the lower right and what
practices are
dropping down to those things versus the
ones which are clear
win-wins okay um and yes sir please now
you'll have to go over again I'm
sorry can I take about 2 minutes to
share how we have achieved climate smart
Agriculture and benefited in India yes
so TR if you would try to be very
concise and also to be I take two
minutes and and try to frame a question
as well later on but first I would like
to congratulate Todd for bringing out a
very precise analysis of what is
happening and what benefits have
occurred and if this taken further then
the world Community will benefit now
climate smart agriculture we started in
Gujarat India about 10 years back and we
called it as a new extension approach it
is prior to agriculture season it takes
place in all Villages together 18,000
Villages team is led by
agriculture extension Administration
agriculture scientist input dealer and
Market people and they go and meet the
farmers at their
doorstep provide them information what
crops they should grow in next season
based on prevailing
situation three inputs are provided to
Farmer one is soil Health analysis which
I mentioned in the last uh session that
what crops their soil will sustain based
on the weather parameters second is what
is market demand for the crops which
crops they should select based on the
market and where the quality inputs are
available this is backed by water
conservation measure at Village level
which is funded by the government with
Community participation so not a drop of
water goes out 70% % of our area is
rainfed focus is on women farmers and
Rural Youth and Rural youth are trained
to identify what are microenterprises
possibilities based on local agriculture
produce so it's a comprehensive approach
takes place every year prior to
agriculture season and what has happened
in Gujarat India and which is now going
on all over the country uh the all
health card approach and everything is
that we had a minus 2% to plus 2% growth
rate we have now reached 9% growth rate
in 10 years at constant price so almost
income of farmers have doubled and on
par with nonfarm sector so if we follow
this approach in a comprehensive manner
there will be less social turmoils which
are happening in many parts of world and
people are trying to grab Justice by
brutality thank
you okay uh thank you very much for this
comment and I'm going to ask uh your
your intervention first
please okay my name is talent tunzi and
um I'm with fan my question is basically
on on coordination taking into account
that um CSA is at a global level and
also we have got the CSA Alliance at at
at the African level how are the
coordination modal modality is do we
have an implementation framework or a
monitoring and evaluation framework at a
global level that resonates with other
regions and are we following a bottom up
approach in terms of coming up with
those uh with those kinds of Frameworks
and the other the other question is on
the on the CSA Technologies do we have
context specific CSA toolkit or
technologies that we have to really say
this is what we call climate smart
agriculture or it's just the three
indicators that were showed here that
indicate on food security adaptation and
mitigation do we have practical context
specific um toolkits that are talking to
different eot types uh in in the
different regions that we are operating
in thank you thank you very much for
this excellent question so what I would
suggest is that uh Alexandre and and
Austin you could try to respond to the
Indian gentleman's point which I think
was very context specific and I think it
makes sense to sort of look at the
question from a larger perspective is it
transferable can it be done elsewhere
you know what are the constraints and
because we talk about systems that are
context specific we need to make sure
that they actually fit somewhere else
and then Todd if you answer uh Doug's
question of course and Rami I don't know
if you want to step in also looking at
uh the questions of coordination
potentially so
Alexander
um so the first thing is
that which is why I was saying that
we're a bit une easy with this idea of
climate Smart Technologies and climate
smart practices because it is very
context dependent it's ecosystem
dependent but it's also socially
dependent it depends how the communities
are organized it it depends how the
policies are supporing it depends of the
economics and
so from our perspective what what we
need is is having more examples of what
has worked or what has not worked with
the various impacts and why it has
worked or why it has not work what what
what is the context which is around the
object the ultimate objective would be I
don't know if it would be toolkits but
information tools knowledge platforms
col it how you want it where
practitioners or actors at whatever
level from governments policy makers
of development practitioners or or
Farmers could go and have a look at
situations which are as comparable as
possible to theirs or one aspect of the
situation is comparable to there so
that's the objective and you're right it
needs a lot of coordination this is this
event is part of it uh the huge work
with done by Todd is an essential
element of that uh but there is still a
lot to be done but probably one the
biggest from my perspective the biggest
mistake to avoid would be to say oh
that's a solution just implement it top
down this does doesn't wouldn't work and
not only it wouldn't work but there is a
risk of having wrong impacts in another
Dimensions I think one of the important
thing with climate SM is that we say in
the beginning you have to look at the
three things you do not necessarily need
to address them at the same level the
win-win-win thing is a myth maybe but
you need to look at the three and you
need to know what damage you're doing in
another dimension when you want to do
something and that's probably true for
all natural resources issues or or even
development issued but and and uh uh
yeah maybe I'll and and this probably is
part of why the quarter and and what so
many trade up because it it's not the
same everywhere but probably you you'll
be more able to enter that
way okay uh thank you very much I'll
start uh from where Al
Alexander has stopped on the two kets
yes or no um in some areas we are trying
uh to draft some to Kits
or some messages on climate smart
agricultural practices I'll give an
example of the Epic uh projects in
Vietnam Zambia and Malawi where we have
looked at the we have started looking at
the trade
tradeoffs uh in terms of medication all
those triple winds medication food
security and adaptation and we have
isolated some examples or some
practices that are fitting well within
those winwin win uh we are also doing
some institutional mapping uh on how to
move on or outscale these practices and
we
have we are also doing some policy
harmonization
I think my colleague Shema indicated
that in some areas or some
regions we have a gap between the
environmental sector and the
agricultural sector uh from policy and
institutional setup on how to handle uh
the issue of
agricultural practices that are climate
smart uh from my colleague from
India uh that's a very good example that
he has indicated and he I'm happy that
uh a few months ago I was in
martra and I I observed the same uh best
practices on what they were calling the
advisory
Services uh within martra they were able
to combine the water
budgets uh the Hydromet Services the
weather
Focus uh the available water for
irrigation the onset of the
RS and the preing economic and social
conditions the markets the
agroecological conditions the soil
fertility to precisely advise the
farming community on how they can um um
modify or improve their farming system
and I really agree with him that it has
really improved the productivity of the
farmers but also um the resilience of
the farming system